I see Rory given your what happened
there was left on the bad side there's
also someone can't believe I'm here just
yeah thanks for looking too good last I
saw this this world of Westeros and all
the attendant stories that teach
anyone's look like these people this
look like the world will first of all
feel like I started this in 1991 and the
show I didn't have my friend meeting
with David Mann until 2007 believe it
was there were like 16 years before the
shows a twinkle in anyone's eye and I
had very strong pictures of what
Westeros look like and when the
characters look like but these people
have worked at characters like you know
amazingly does it think the effective
rate since when he wasn't destroyed you
continue to write there's a visit new
it's warm what you not not really
I knew that those 16 years that sort of
deep root before the show didn't I
sometimes it gets a little tricky but
the show is the show and the books other
books and they are and keep them
separate I know a few of the actors that
read the book so many of them don't
before they became a cast members on the
show
is that something that you all know or
not or not as the case may be in 70 is
the prerequisite obviously hey God you
guys clearly were fans of the books
right when she first contact me eight
years ago it is a long time and then how
did you manage to get it going with
because it clearly this is something
that costs a great deal of money to put
together how do you - okay - you and
sorry Duke record the story before it
will get a very long lunch where we told
them what the bundles do with annotation
and and we had a creator talking very
individual said okay okay who is Jon
Snow's real moment and there was a very
long pause and I look at throughout to
guess and he did say yes or no
let's hear that so you should most of
the time and you ocean belfast except
you make everything now we shoot in
belfast you're through the entire
shooting season but we also have other
four locations which vary from year to
year this year it's going to be croatia
and spain ambassadors we finish in Malta
and Morocco and Iceland the subject
matter of the show can be thanked that
way controversial is that something that
you know sometimes you go to a
conservative area perhaps where they
aren't happy but you think that as you
get his film that happen this year yes
location did not once is property to be
involved with hormones at least remember
the views expecially for legal reasons
the actress or still with us does it
concern you when you receive the spreads
that you know this may be it does it
worry you that you yeah I mean so most
micro people happens the book small
characters but I know that David down
kill characters that still live with us
and I'm vice versa so we every know so I
just lucked out to never ask for rage
simply provide that I think what we're
going to do I believe is that we have
some new cast members that you want to
talk about as well is that right sure
yeah yes yeah big season coming up a
whole bunch of new characters and we
thought they'd say love you themselves
so you'll be getting attached to it
watch die for a blade over the next 18
months I don't want to take up a whole
lot of time from this panel today no
giving you a chance to talk because
obviously there are a great many members
of the cast here so I want to kind of
throw it to the floor quite quickly so
that we can get as many questions as
possible for the five so I waited as you
say overnight
please identify yourself and speak
coherent a big guest yes David say if
you do us a favor and don't ask us
what's gonna happen next season oh yeah
no obviously there'll be no spoilers
here
I also if you do know what happens in
the books and then you want to ask
questions about stuff that have you know
athletes not quite yet my name is Rick
my question is for mr. Park and as the
creator of this humorous I'm wondering
if there is any of the many gods of
deities that you most closely associate
yourself with and if I may suggest one
perhaps the many-faced God because you
killed our community I have plenty of
unity no I don't think I choose any one
God over the other and my reputation for
killing is saturated then are funnier
than I am
they've killed a number of Erica's who
are still alive and both so you know I
mean I may only be the second ranked
murderer here on the panel but no I I
think religion is important world them
should be depicted but I'm not about to
endorse one westeros religion is true
over the others my question is for
Harrington
that's true that's true I wanted to ask
you what do you do to prepare for your
roles on the wall you know before battle
scenes also increasing cold and just
what do you do before hands are there I
think I think with Thrones
it's we look at work that's done for you
before you can get there and I think a
big part of that for me is costume
because we have such wonderful costumes
on the show when I find put it on and
it's got something weight to it
something sort of gives us 7 gravity
that I I can't
it's when I'm about to go back and start
my first day on Monday which is really
exciting
I've got sea bass it's all just up my
hair tie everything I get back into that
costume and it's very smooth playground
and that's kind of icing for season two
and three and so that it was absolutely
freezing sinister agent actually follow
me well cause um but they never knew
there were times where she's like -
Ortiz but we have these fellas onto me
because you say that and then you have a
backlog on but no it is it is beautiful
it's mesmerizing being in Iceland but
it's a kind of competence I can't wait
to operation yeah yeah what this show
really excels in is putting the actors
into the same environment as the
characters the counter-offensive well
we're in Iceland especially we thought
we were walking on the ground
we're actually walking on five feet of
compacted snow so if you get my costume
with weighs a fair amount its own put me
in it which we shall never help anything
then I'll be charging across a place
you're being chased by a camera on a
quad bike chances are by given day I've
been driven into the ground like a
tenday people say oh you know those
questions people must really keep you on
and they do but from the neck down and
as an actor you can't be so that's all
because your face is freezing on please
please please not - 35 you're a boiler
you think okay
I'd if I never this cold again in my
life
something's wrong so many questions for
George gave me them as the pacing of the
show has really sped up and caught up
almost to where dancing dragons is how
will you go forward planning this
throughout the next few seasons and
years as well this surpass as far as the
timeline of the Lord which one will end
first I'm going to wait Jacob it's a
fantastic question and you can't answer
without telling what's gonna happen so
oh how is it working you know all of the
different sets and how do you manage to
bring together all these different
stories twisting and turning into one
great art that just has an epic feel to
it and it's a real world it all starts
in George's mind and I'll start a new
furnace grant how many years ago George
30 years ago thank you many one minute
over 30 73 years ago yeah and you know
this characters every single character
sitting up here at the stables started
out in some corporations they all send a
little bit like Parmesan cheese farms
I like cheese fantasy is very hard
muttering away a quest for us but we've
recently came out with a map book where
they wouldn't beat a romance in the
entire world and we have the world of
Ice and Fire ago in October which is
like Gordon see you know I'm dream maps
for places like thousands of miles to
East but a story will never go and I'm
just running out of names way the
shortening a mist evening on [ __ ] use
the Misty Mountains really sure you know
you do the best you can
hey you didn't use the thing that was
criticizing yes it looks like we have an
emissary from another Kingdom hello for
me for someone say no the only world in
semester you describe the process of hey
you guys look amazing live away yeah
man see I think badly about muscles you
better hide the legs I'll see you in
town
Oh
HBO team set me up with master Mushin
very early in the process actually put
me into some training with a guy named
Esther who in Los Angeles and then of
course I was on set in Belfast doing the
extensive rehearsals with the CC Smith
and the fight team and a half RB the
other actor and I had an amazing build I
mean come on guys I could ask the same
actually over my quaint little react say
and the Euro fight scenes of are very
complicated and difficult phases did you
do that before this was it's a skill
alone in Provence go or instead are you
actually sort me in your life really
amazing all of us were very patient and
deal with this with radiant humor
ticking me communiques low takes a while
of her to sink in and you work hard but
it's always with the girl that you
wanted to be as brilliant as it possibly
can be and they facilitate that yes yes
I mean I had a great teacher once called
a vlogger they was just amazing and that
was years ago and he said needs now yes
you need a sword wasn't that just
amazing there was College sword fighting
Neels the end of the stick